[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
bueno buenas noches a todos yo hoy
quiero empezar por el final quiero
empezar dando las gracias gracias
primero a la vida
que me ha dado la oportunidad de estar
hoy aquí sana y salva gracias a carmen y
a toda la organización por decidir un
día romper molde y traerse un formato
con él como éste con lo difícil que es
traer cosas como esta esta ciudad
muchísimas gracias y gracias sobre todo
por aquel momento de inspiración que
decidió alguien que yo podía aportar hoy
algo aquí espero de verdad estar al
nivel y espero que este ratito os llene
yo hoy
voy a traer conmigo
aquí traigo a la doctora romero conmigo
la famosa como no con su bata y tal pero
a mí me gustaría que hoy todos sabéis
sepáis más cosas sobre mí vale
aunque no lo creáis yo nací en granada'
nací en canadá hace tanto no nos vamos a
desnudar tanto es que no hay tanta
confianza y desde pequeña era una niña
súper inquieta en la teoría de cuerdas
que hemos visto esta tarde yo era la
gran vibrador a vale y volvía a mi madre
loca absolutamente loca metía los
enchufes miraba todo pero otra cosa que
hacía también era que me encantaba el
teatro me encantaba cantar cantaba en un
coro le decía a mi madre que me apuntara
todos los instrumentos puestos a cantar
yo tocaba todos los palos con lo cual mi
madre estaba como muy sorprendida de ver
qué es lo que podía pasar conmigo no
para acabarlo de empatar cuando alguien
me hacía un regalo principalmente si
eran muñecas a mí me daba por arrancar
las piernas ponerle esmalte rojo y luego
las arreglaba con lo cual cuando mi
madre se sentaba en esas conversaciones
de padres de a ver qué va a pasar con
esta niña yo creo que el diagnóstico
diferencial que ella movía era bueno
pues puede ser que no salga médico
pero también puede ser que ese artista
mi abuela hablando de abuelo hoy eran
las que opinaba aquello era una pedazo
de artista pero también nos movíamos
dentro de la psicopatía a veces que esta
niña es psicópatas y no lo sabemos
vale en ese interín de todo lo que
estaba pasando yo un día con 12 3 añitos
veo un reportaje de esta maravillosa
mujer de jane goldman y ella habla le
hacen una pregunta fantástica sobre en
qué momento piensa ella que nosotros nos
separamos de los chimpancés vale en qué
momento empieza la civil la
sensibilización y ella dice yo pensaba
quiero hablar de la cerámica yo decía
eso ya me lo he estudiado yo lo de
historia o lo de la cultura no no no no
ella dijo algo que a mí me impactó
muchísimo dijo en aquel momento en que
se descubrió un fémur que había sido
reparado en una sociedad no humana en
ese momento empezó la civilización
porque alguien decidió de una persona
que en ese momento era débil se iba a
quedar con ella la iba a cuidar
para que luego cuando estuviera al nivel
de la sociedad pudiera entrar dentro del
grupo de los nómadas y volver otra vez a
competir y aquello se me quedó grabado a
fuego y yo miré a mi madre y le dije
mamá yo me quiero dedicar a cuidar a la
gente y para cuidar a la gente lo que
decidí era que me iba a efe el médico
bueno pues tomate en el sueño sueño
grande yo lo que quería era la vacuna
contra el cáncer del mama y dije me voy
a apuntar y voy a hacer una carrera solo
para descubrir la vacuna del cáncer de
mama y por qué porque mi amigo mi abuela
había muerto de cáncer de mama y yo
había vivido no saben ustedes la
experiencia que es vivir que tu padre la
referente de fuerza que tú tienes lo ves
llorar y ves y te cuenta lo que afecta
que una madre joven desaparezca de su
casa y en ese momento me fui a la
facultad de medicina y me fui a la
facultad de medicina cargada de sueño y
me fui a la facultad de medicina a
hacerlo y en la medicina a cabo claro y
viene el mir y en el mío me puse a rezar
todo lo que sabía para que me llegara la
sabiduría al examen y yo pudiera probar
porque claro tenía tú mí ya toda mi
familia y eso lo pasamos y
afortunadamente ese examen cambió mi
vida porque pues porque me trajo a
toledo y en toledo
me hice radiólogo y de repente me
dediqué a vigilar
a ese enemigo que yo tenía aquí desde
pequeña
digamos que actuar sobre él y como no
podía ser de otra manera un día me dicen
tienes que encargarte de montar la mamá
en toledo yo dije ya que vamos y tuve mi
primera paciente mi primera paciente en
la que reconocí
ese enemigo unas calcificaciones chicas
joven 37 años un bebé de apenas cinco
meses revisión de su ginecólogo no tengo
nada no tengo nada solo vengo a revisar
que todo sigue bien y cuando yo vi eso
me armé de valor y dije voy a hablar con
esta mujer porque yo me había formado en
eeuu y yo ya sabía en ese momento que
había una cosa que se llamaba biopsia
que podía hacer adelantarnos a todo y la
convencí la convencí la apreté las manos
dije vamos a por ello y ella me dejó no
lo sabía entonces que yo no había hecho
nunca ninguna pero me dejó e hicimos la
biopsia sacamos ese pequeño cáncer de
mama y llegó el momento cuando ya
teníamos todo esto aunque yo dije yo
quiero seguir acompañando a esta mujer
porque esta mujer no conoce a nadie
tiene su bebé me habla o de él yo ya la
conozco quiero que ser yo la que esté
con ella y entonces
resonancia y le cité todo aquello que
era la información del enemigo que
necesitábamos conocer para aplicar el
tratamiento y llegó el día en que mis
compañeros me dicen tiene un cáncer de
mama y en ese momento como estaba
articulado el tema era que se lo
decíamos a su ginecólogo a su cirujano y
él la llamaba y yo dije no la quiero
llamar yo porque ella no conoce a nadie
y quiero ser yo la que se lo diga y
cuando yo la llamé y me senté con ella y
le dije tiene un cáncer de mama ella se
derrumbó porque en todo momento ella
pensaba que como era joven como tenía un
niño como era necesaria como cuidaba a
sus padres ella no le podía pasar nada
porque los jóvenes pensamos que la salud
viene por añadidura y ella se derrumbó y
se puso a llorar y en ese momento tan
bestial yo me quedé sin palabra porque
porque me di cuenta que yo que había
sacado matrícula en farmacología sabía
todo sobre la patología sabía todo en la
universidad me han dado todo tipo de
armas conocía hasta los cadáveres y las
moscas que generaban que se lo contaba a
mi madre a la hora de comer les daba la
comida todo
no sabía hablar con los pacientes porque
nadie me enseñó nunca eso y lo único que
se me ocurrió en ese momento fue
agarrarle la mano y guardar silencio
hasta que ya se calmó y cuando ya se
calmó lo único que le dije es esto no es
una tumba esto es un túnel estamos
muchos al otro lado preparados para
tirar de las manos y que tus pases este
proceso y así lo hicimos y entonces nos
agarramos de las manos continuamos el
proceso y llegó la hora de la cirugía
conservadora hay que poner un arpón yo
explicándole a ella lo que las pone en
lugar del cirujano y qué es un arpón
esto que están viendo usted de aquí se
coge una cosita pequeña y se consigue
una cirugía con bordes limpios y ella si
su cirugía conservadora se hizo su
radioterapia se hizo su quimioterapia y
me apareció el famoso día de la revisión
del final del proceso y yo le dije
enhorabuena cariño porque estás limpia
enhorabuena porque estás curada y ella
rompió a llorar se abrazó a mí y lo que
me dijo es le doy la gracias pero no le
doy las gracias por curar
y eso lo tiene dios en sus manos la vela
gracias por cómo me ha cuidado
y cuando yo vi lo que ella me transmitía
dije este es el camino esto es lo que
hay que hacer porque no somos solamente
personas técnicas aquí hay seres humanos
detrás y hay que aprender a conectar con
sus emociones y esto es lo importante
porque podemos ser cada uno en nuestra
especialidad de una manera o de otra
da igual que hagamos papeles que demos
clases pero pongamos el corazón hay que
cuidar a la gente y quiera cuidar para
mí dar charlas autoexploración meterme
en los colegios todo el mundo sabe que
en todos los saraos me meto estoy
encantada y la siguiente cosas
importante empatizar con esa gente tener
la humildad de que ellos te digan a la
cara a los defectos que tienen los que
tienen tu unidad los problemas que han
tenido recoger fondo la tarta solidaria
que tenía y la foto saber qué
necesidades tienen la medicina necesita
ser humilde para poder mejorar y todo
esto no lo hace una persona sola yo
vengo a deciros que tengo un equipo
maravilloso hay que trabajar hay que
saber trabajar en equipo hay que tener
gente
hay que saber transmitir todo porque si
yo no transmito las cosas en que no solo
he acertado como está sino en aquellas
que me he equivocado
esas son todavía más importante porque
sino la gente sufre hay que ser generoso
con la gestión del conocimiento y cuando
se trabaja en equipo y se hace todo esto
se consiguen cosas tan maravillosas como
que el cumpleaños el día 19 de octubre
que el día del cáncer de mama lo
celebremos con las mujeres pero qué pasa
ahora viene el coche
y la super doctora romero la que tenía
las herramientas la que sabía todo la
que empatizaba la que las mujeres
adoraban se para mi vida se para mi vida
se para la muestra también el kobe viene
reina el silencio y realidad e
incertidumbre y de repente a los médicos
nos quitan el manual de instrucciones
y qué ocurre qué hace un radiólogo os
preguntaréis bueno pues eso también me
lo pregunte yo pues un radiólogo
principalmente nos llevan a urgencias me
paralizan la unidad de mama en aquel
momento no podíamos hacer nada ya lo
sabéis teníamos todo ocupado por kobe y
de repente me encuentro diagnosticando
autora diagnosticando neumonía ayudando
a la gente diagnosticando complicaciones
subiendo a la uvi
en aquel horror en el que nos quitaron
insisto el manual de instrucciones nos
quitaron toda la seguridad que uno tiene
de la evidencia científica y de los años
de estudio en aquel horror yo tenía en
mi cabeza otra cosa y era dios mío qué
está pasando con mis pacientes porque yo
tenía mujeres que estaban diagnosticadas
de un cáncer de mama que ya no sabían
que estaban esperando su quirófano y que
tuvimos que llamarla y decirle esto se
suspende sine díe y yo no hacía nada más
que pensar cómo estarán estas mujeres en
su casa sin poderse apoyar en su familia
sin poder hacer nada sin saber si como
ellas me decían me va a matar el
más fuera que dentro y en ese momento lo
que decidimos desde la unidad de mamá
era trabajar de manera importante las
llamadas telefónicas y yo después de
hacer mi trabajo me ponía a llamarla y
llamaba a todas las mujeres que tenían
con cáncer de mama pendientes en lista
de espera y ahora vamos juntas porque
había veces que me dicen y por qué sigue
llamando digo porque alguien necesita
una ventana donde gritar
donde saber que no son números porque
una de las cosas más horribles que ha
tenido esta enfermedad es que no hemos
podido tener contacto emocional ni
despedirnos de los seres queridos y eso
por encima de todo era mi tope personal
y cuando todo pasó y empezamos con ese
primer quirófano la primera paciente
vino y cuando me vio aparecer por el
pasillo y ella me reconoció y una
reconocía a ella una persona con la que
habíamos hablado que ya había hablado de
su hijo ella se sentó en la cama ella es
vienen en cama se sentó en la cama y se
puso a aplaudirme y nosotros le
aplaudimos a ella y ahí se produjo una
magia se produjo un abrazo y les puedo
asegurar que yo la ostra romero la
famosa la premiada afortunadamente tengo
muchísimo que agradecer a esta tierra
porque me ha querido muchísimo pero no
he tenido un premio mayor que aquel
abrazo y eso es lo que me gustaría
transmitirlo no hay ningún premio
científico ni ningún sueldo ni nada
mayor que el reconocimiento y el abrazo
y el agradecimiento de saber qué
o bien con alguien
y que os quería decir
os quería decir que no hay sueños
pequeños os quería decir que muchas
veces uno tiene que ser rompedor y
plantearse que se puede traer un test de
américa o que se puede traer una beca de
investigación claro que sí hay que
trabajar siempre con ideas os podría
decir que todo lleva trabajo trabajo y
trabajo pero también mucha ilusión y no
venirse abajo y os podría decir que a
veces una sonrisa un apretón de mano un
como estas a veces esas cosas tan
pequeñas cambian la vida a la gente
vosotros marcan la diferencia de lo que
queréis a vuestro alrededor no
desprecies las cosas pequeñas porque las
cosas pequeñas te llevan a dar una gran
alegría quizá lo mejor de todo esto lo
único realmente bueno que ha pasado con
todo este horror es que aprendamos que
nuestra abuela
llevaba en razón ella nos decía lo
importante en la salud en la salud y la
familia la familia que tiene y la
familia que es cosa que escoge que son
tus amigos
hay que refugiarse en ello no estemos
tan metidos en nuestra rutina diaria que
no seamos capaces de valorar el
potencial que tenemos el potencial que
tenemos cuando besamos cuando abrazamos
o cuando hacemos a alguien sonreír esa
es nuestra fortaleza y es lo que nos
separa de los chimpancés y por eso yo
hoy quiero como profesional de eso es
tan necesario que sea hablado después de
haber pasado todo lo que he pasado
quiero darle las gracias a las mujeres
de castilla-la mancha' por todo lo que
me han enseñado por todo lo que me han
apoyado dar las gracias en nombre de
todos esos profesionales a vuestro
aplauso de la 8 darle las gracias a la
empatía que hemos encontrado con la
gente con el respeto que entraba en
urgencias como diciendo no les queremos
molestar dar las gracias porque por
primera vez hemos sido lo que somos
humanos y civilizados
así que aprovecho este enorme canal para
dado en nombre de todos nosotros un gran
aplauso
[Aplausos]
[Música]